I've never had red vines or Twizzlers in  my life I never really ate Twizzlers  because I was allergic to them and then  I didn't even know red vines were a  thing until pretty recently I'm from  Scotland and to the best of my knowledge  we don't have either of these I  appreciate the texture it feels kind of  cool I don't like this it tastes kind of  like medicinal it's like play-doh meets  robitussin it doesn't taste like a sweet  candy like I don't know why you would  eat this this is quite yummy a taste of  this one is way more bearable this one's  like harder to chew though it tastes  kind of like a muted gummy bear it  tastes more fresh I like the second one  better I definitely preferred number two  I guess I liked Twizzlers more than red  vines  you just got to do you if you like red  vines keep eating red lines if you liked  whistlers eat Twizzlers and I'm gonna  mix it in here in either and that's okay  too